[Music]
hey everybody thanks for joining us for
one of the late sessions sticking it out
til the end of the day I will call out
that there is one more session after
this on Gmail add-ons I also an Apps
Script related product you guys check it
out if you really want to go big tonight
on next but we're going to talk now
about Apps Script and a new monitoring
capability that's been made possible
with our integration with stackdriver
logging that's currently in an early
access program and it's planned for
launch to G suite business customers and
possibly more broadly down the line and
with me here is ro man from rep of all
and he's going to be covering most of
the presentation he is truly the expert
on this one of our earliest adopters and
has figured out how to hook it up to
several other cloud technologies to
extract maximum value from stackdriver
logging and so I'll just I'll give a
quick overview of what we're going to
talk about and what the technology is
and then I'll hand it over to RO man so
first we're just going to talk about
stack driver logging in Apps Script and
how the integration works no man will
give an example based on yet another
mail merge which is a product that he
has built and manages and we're gonna
talk about how you can get your logs
from stack driver into bigquery for
analysis and do a lot of more powerful
stuff with them and then another example
a firebase example and then finally data
studio and so Romanus really done our
work for us in identifying all of the
ways that you can leverage this data
once you get it in the stack driver and
so I the the basics are that we now
define console dot star methods and the
familiar logging methods from the
JavaScript client in the browser and
messages and I should also say objects
and values of other types that you log
to console get sent to a stack driver
logging you can also configure Apps
Script to law
exceptions to stock driver logging this
is particularly powerful if you're
building an add-on or something that has
a large user base you want to keep track
of whether it's working for people other
than yourself in environments other than
your own and the existing logging
solution is frankly not up to snuff it
captures the most recent set of logs and
so when you're working with a large user
base you really need something richer
and so here in project properties you
can check the log exceptions box and and
you're off and running I here in the
View menu there's new menu item for
people participating in the EAP or once
the feature rolls out to view your
console logs and and here you see logs
in in the stack driver logging interface
and a couple hints at other cool stuff
you can do creating metrics and exports
and then you can also filter by either
the metadata that we send along with the
message or the message itself if you're
sending a JSON object as your as your
log message we also automatically in
addition to some other metadata we
automatically tagged every log entry
with a with a user key and and this is
this is done for two purposes firstly it
just makes it easy for you to see what's
happening to a particular user and the
other reason that we do this is as kind
of a serving suggestion these keys are
don't contain PII they're based on the
user's identity and they rotate once a
month and so this is kind of extending a
Google practice to you to use if you
like and to track users for short
periods of time and make sure the
application is working for them but to
protect their privacy by not tracking
them over a really long period of time
and you can log other keys you can log
the users email address for example and
your script has access to it and so this
is something that you would use for
support and triaging issues and it's a
great way to do that in a way that
protects your users privacy
and I'll hand it off to Rome and for the
rest of the shell thank you okay so I'm
going to present how I will how I have
started to use stackdriver
logging with my add on yet resume image
so yet resume image is not on for Google
sheets self-sufficient errand
meaning that it doesn't connect to any
other SAS service it's ready lives only
as an add-on it's a minimal atom so it
lets you send email campaigns using
Gmail and Google Spreadsheets it's one
of the top add-ons for Google
Spreadsheets so this means that we are
now at 700,000 installations so 700,000
people have yet Rosamund melt installed
on their Gmail Google account but we do
have a great number of monthly active
user more than 80 thousand monthly users
sending email campaign with yet rosa
mail merge every month for a total of
more than 40 million emails send monthly
and all that means that we do have to
provide support to a lot of people using
this tool even if it's quite simple to
use many people still need help or still
have issue with it and this logging tool
like stackdriver logging is really
helpful to investigate better understand
all the steps user went through before
you had an issue and so I will
demonstrate how we're using that now
to help in your support and in other
part of the development of the atom so
first just to present AB it's yet
another mail merge so it's yeah quite
simple to use you simply start so it's a
tool to create mail merge campaign email
campaigns so to send the same email to a
bunch of different people and you start
by creating draft in Gmail where you
will be able to place some place orders
that will be replaced by a data from
your spreadsheet so for example here we
have a placeholder first name here and
in the spreadsheet you can see that in
the first column column a there's a
column named first name and so for each
row of a spread of the thread sheet yet
another mail merge will send an email
and we'll reuse all term plate the email
draft and replace in these draft markers
by the data from the spreadsheets so to
install yet another mail merge in a
spreadsheet you just have to go to the
add-ons though as or via my new add-ons
get add-ons and you will see so many
much pretty easily as it's as I said one
of the top add-ons usually it's among
the top six add-ons that you can find
directly when you launch into the
gallery after that so add-ons are
available via a specific menu in each
spreadsheet and for each Rossum image
you have several menus to to trigger the
add-on function so you can either
directly start the merge if you already
have a spreadsheet containing contacts
recipients or you can use one of our
integration to import contacts either
from Google contacts of ourselves from
Salesforce and so on
police also checked our configure from
submission while different other
features so you did you indicate
everything you want so mostly you select
the draft you want to reuse to send your
email campaigns so we list all drafts
from your gmail account and then you can
for example at said if you want to track
emails open clicked bounced and so on
if you want to set up a specific areas
add some personalized attachments and
many other options that we added over
the years for the add-on and once you've
sent you campaign into spreadsheets
directly you are able to see the result
of your campaign in real time so the
add-on display information in a little
sidebar and also update merge status :
letting you know so how many people have
either opened or clicked on your email
okay so that's the that was just an
introduction to explain how the whatsit
resume eaters a mail merge does as we
have a lot of users we we thought it was
interesting to track usage learn how
people are using or add-on and for that
since more than a year now we are evilly
using Google Analytics because it let us
see the exact number of users using the
add-on every month day and so on and to
track the usage of different features so
before going to the stag river logging
part I want to show what we were using
before stock driver and when we
I did to switch and what decided us to
switch some some parts from Google
Analytics to to Stack Overflow to stag
writer so in Google Analytics you are
able to easily see your active users the
norm of the number of daily active users
seven-day active users or monthly active
users you are able to compare over time
those those users so you are able to see
if the number of users is increasing
from month to month also if you are on a
gross or if there are some issues
because less and less people are using
your add-on we are also able to track
several events so for example as yet
another mail merge is a mail merge tool
to send email campaigns while we are
sending to analytics information about
those emails campaign so we are able to
see how many emails campaigns where a
sent over a specific period of time how
many emails were sent per campaign and
as a total and we can also send a lot
more information to Google Analytics to
get information about which features
people are using and so on so for
example I presented earlier that in your
Gmail Draft you can put place order
markers so that the email won't look
exactly the same for every user but will
be a bit personalized but not everybody
is using it in fact yes more than 36
percent of all users are sending the
exact same message to everybody and I
don't have that on the slides but that's
something we have actually improved so
there were a lot
people not using any kind of
personalization before and because of
because we track this kind of
information we were able to better
indicates to people how to personalize
their emails and once they knew that
that was possible they use that features
as so the ratio has increased in favor
of more people using placeholders as
time goes by it's the same for or email
tracking feature now pretty much
everyone is using it and before it was
not the case and thanks to all the data
we are collecting we were able to see
where we we needed to make improvements
to be sure that people know that the
feature existed and that it was useful
for them and yeah we're tracking several
data like that mostly thanks to the
ability to create custom dimension in
Google Analytics that lets you as sent a
specific data related to your app your
add-on to analytics so like if the
people have activated one feature in
your app or or so to categorize the
people so is it mostly used by gmail.com
users by district users how many people
are using and also paying for the
product it's a freemium product so some
people are using it and sending emails
for free and some others are paying what
is the proportion and so on so all that
were very interested in interesting
metric interesting metrics for us and we
improve our usage of Google Analytics
over time and so we were also using
Google Analytics to track arrows so that
was good because we were able to see
thanks to all the charts and default
report things available in Google
Analytics directly the number of times a
specific error happened the number of
users impacted and so we were able to
know on which error we needed to be
proactive and find a fix quickly but
apart from that sending arrows to
analytics is a bit restrictive because
you can only send a simple string of
errors and you don't have all the stack
of the error and it's not really great
to investigate and understand why this
error is happening
so that's why it will be better to
activate cloud logging and that's what
we did we activated in a true thermal
image the connection with tag driver and
now we are able to see in real time all
the arrows happening on the on the atom
so every time someone is using the
add-on and is generating an error we can
see the log in real time and we can
click on a specific log to have all the
information about the log so for which
we usually impacted on which function at
which specific line of code in the
script and so on and so on all those
information are really helpful to
investigate and find a solution so the
question was was it interesting for us
to switch to stag river logging knowing
that we already have a lot of stuff in
place with Google Analytics and was it
in fact
does it make sense to totally forget
about Google Analytics and go all start
over or should we use both of them and
we are trying to answer that question so
the all the advantages of stock driver
is that it's well it's easier to see all
arrows linked to a specific user in
Google Analytics you mostly have
aggregated data but you it's difficult
to see precisely what is happening for a
specific user with tag driver we can
enter a specific user key linked to a
user and we can see everything that's
happening for the specific user plus we
do have all the text actress traces to
have all the details about the error and
it's really easy to use in fact we don't
have to we only have to check a box in
the app script editor and all the arrows
start flowing into stackdriver and also
the logs are available in real time so
that has been very helpful in the recent
weeks when we deployed a new version of
the add-on because it's not always
possible to launch perfect updates and
if you see new arrows you are able to
quickly react and update and push a new
version the limitation that we saw is a
stye River logging is mostly that the
there's no real metric capability so
this means that it's not easy or not
possible to directly from stock River
logging you I see the number of people
impacted by your specific error
see the top recurring arrows on your
script and so on the good news is that
it's possible to export logs to bigquery
and when you do that it solve the
previous limitation because we can
aggregate the data available in stock
right for logging in bigquery in any way
we want and that's what I will show show
you now so it's very easy to a set up
export to to bigquery in the cloud
console you only have to click on a few
buttons to to set that up
and once that is set up logs are sent to
bigquery in real time using streaming
insert new table is created everyday you
don't have to create the table schema or
anything and it's good because you can
decide if you want to keep all the logs
forever
or you can set up expiration date on the
tables to be sure that you won't be
invoiced too much at the end of the
month because bigquery has a fridge here
but if you are stirring a too much data
in bigquery it's going to cost you
something at some point and so usually
those kinds of logs are useful for a few
days or a month or something like that
and it's possible to say to bigquery
okay I only want to keep those data for
a month on that that's all
also directly in stock driver if you are
using the free version of stock driver
logs are only kept for seven days so if
you want to increase that
using the bigquery integration does help
because you can save all logs for ever
if you want so once the data are in
bigquery you you can make queries as I
said so the logs are splits in daily
tables but it's easy to perform queries
over multiple daily table within a date
range so it means that you don't have to
look at the errors per day but you can
look at the rows over a period of days
so for example among the useful queries
we will I will explain a bit right after
the how we write or queries but among
the useful queries we have you can for
example see the number of arrows opening
every days and the number of impacted
users so that's just basic statistics
but it doesn't tell you where it's
happening exactly so you can also list
the most recurring errors on the script
and also look at the number of impacted
users for those zeros so you will know
which from which arrow to fix while some
most of those errors are errors
happening on google sides and it's just
a matter of adding more retry or when it
fails but it lets you quickly see if
there's something you can fix to improve
the info tab you can see also the number
of errors per function name so to see
also if function specific function
contains more issues than others and to
which part of your code you should take
care most based on all those data and we
are also able to see the number of
arrows generated by each user as Pearl
explained previously when Apps Script is
automatically sending data to
stackdriver each time it's sending a new
arrow log it provides the user key for
the specific user so we are able to
achieve as some users are encountering
way more errors than other people and
investigate on that because sometimes
people do have a lot of errors but
aren't reporting any issue - - to us so
it's useful to understand what is
happening and maybe that's something we
can fix because we have simply not not
think about specific use case and so
this will help us investigate and see
that people are using the other one in a
specific way that we haven't sort of and
we can apply your fix to make it work
okay so if we take a look at the query
syntax so first when you want to make a
career in bigquery you have to indicate
the source data to be hurried so usually
it's begins with the ID of the project
on the cloud cloud console every Apps
Script project is linked to a cloud
console project where you can find the
stock driver logs and so for in the case
of electrons a mail merge so we have the
that app script console logs that are
automatically created when we have
activated the synchronization between a
stack reverb and bigquery here we can
indicate with bigquery that we want to
query multiple daily table over a
specific date range so after data will
simply tell that I want to query the
tables from now past to the last seven
days to have all the most fresh errors
I can do my select and indicate if I
want to display issues by date kundi
number of errors and indicate also the
users impacted so we can retrieve the
user key as we were saying before that
is always passed by app script for its
logs into the driver and also we can
indicate that we want only only to
investigate on errors knowing that stock
risers let you log errors but also
author information and we will see that
very soon we can also do a group by to
group ID get a date and get some
aggregate okay so exposed to bigquery
are a very nice addition it's not
available in Google Analytics so Google
Analytics only provide sample data and
sometimes it's not enough if you want an
integration between Google Analytics and
bigquery you have to go to you have to
pay for Google Analytics premium which
is very very expensive and so the
ability to use tank driver with it's
free integration with bigquery is quite
useful so we decided that as Google
Analytics do provide charts and a lot of
metrics right out of the box it makes
sense to continue to use analytics to
track or a number of monthly users the
usage of values feature in the add-on
but it makes it made total sense to stop
logging errors in Google Analytics and
start locking them in stock driver ok
and now we will see how we can send more
logs to stag river in addition to arrows
to better to help you when you want to
push updates or understand how people
are using the the add-on so first I will
do a little demo just because we haven't
shown yet how easy it is to integrate
app script and stackdriver so as we said
before for now it's only available as
part of EA p / trusted tester program so
you don't have it yet but it's rather
easy to add a new line to log
information in app script here we'll
just send a little information to cloud
logging so if I run this function it
logs
automatically this information Instagram
logging and I can then click on view
console logs and as it
the first time as it's a new app script
project
I haven't actually enabled logging
before so he is asking me if I want to
enable exception logging for all future
execution of the script and that's very
useful because this means that without
adding any more lines of code every time
the script produces an error it will be
automatically sent to cloud a to stack
rival logic so here it lets me open the
console project linked to my Apps Script
project opens directly in this console
project my industry project stack River
logging and I can see the information I
just sent with the time stamp my user
key for this project so if multiple
users are using this script they will
have their own user key at its time I
can see that the it has the log has been
sent by the function name my function
that the invocation type is editor and
you it's also make difference if you if
logs are coming from time driven trigger
from a UI of your add-on in the
spreadsheet in the side bar and so on so
it's quite useful to exactly see how the
error happened exactly and so here it's
not an error it's a simple log if I want
to generate an error it's very simple so
here for example yeah mistake in the
code I don't
I haven't put a console that logged but
console that ugh
and so if I start streaming log I should
be able to find the errors so you can
see that here I haven't
answer any new line of code not a
try-catch or anything to send the arrow
back to stackdriver
it's just that among the project
properties log exceptions is checked now
automatically and it means that every
time the script will throw an error I
will be able to find the error in inside
reiver
and that's very useful because you don't
have to yeah add any complexity to your
code and you can benefit from the
feature right away that's all for the
demo if I can go back to the
presentation thank you very much
so in addition to basic info information
like the hello world I just enter it's
also possible to send additional info as
JSON objects so for example here we are
collecting information about the number
of emails sent to better understand if
people are able to send all their emails
in one batch or if they have to do it in
multiple multi in multiple batches and
so on and so you can put a lot of
different information and you will all
retrieve all those information in stag
River logging as reason which is an
output and you can then reuse all those
information to filter the logs as
surprised if you see at the top of the
screen shots there's a little query bar
where you can indicate that you want to
filter the data based on the JSON
payload and that I'm in their JSON
payload so that's really useful
especially when you are underling the
support for the app because if you need
to see
everything that happened to a specific
user who is asking for help well we can
easily add information using or console
that log at every input important point
during the use of the add-on and so for
example I can automatically collect the
remaining delicata knowing that I don't
send the email myself
I'm calling the Gmail API to send emails
and each user has a specific quota to
send emails every day so I can check the
quota before and see how many emails
will be he was able to send in how the
time it did I needed to send all those
emails the remaining quota after that
and so on and so on and with all those
information when someone asked for help
on a support platform were able to check
back the logs for for these users and
this is really helpful to understand
what he has done because every user is
not able to basically describe what he
has done before having a specific issue
and we are able to see all the history
and better help help him understand what
went wrong something we started using
stag river logging in part because due
to change in the Gmail API a lot of
users reported that it it took time to
send emails campaign and so we wanted to
know exactly how many people were
impacted by slow sending time for emails
campaign so we started to tracking that
exactly to track that exactly we
added a different information to
understand what could cause this issue
could it be equally different of the
draft size so for example if you have if
you are attaching a lot of images and
attachments to your draft so you end up
with a 20 megabytes draft that you will
send you that you will send to 1,000
people it means that you will in fact
send 20 gigabyte of data with your
campaign and so that might explain why
some people find it a bit slow so in
fact it was not the reason and we were
able to see that it really simply
depends on the number of emails you you
want to send Gmail the Gmail API as
specific as well first of all to make
sure that you are not sending too many
emails in a very short time and based on
all the data we aggregated with a
photographer were able to update our
documentation to indicate to people the
time needed who has spent the campaign
ads in the campaign based on the
recipients you add and we were we were
able also to update the add-on itself
through one users before they send a
campaign so for example if the there on
the spreadsheet and want to start a
campaign sending emails to more than one
hundred and one thousand and two hundred
users we know that it will take 30
minutes so we display warning it will
take sometimes you will have to leave
your computer's open for some time so do
you want to do it now or do you want to
reschedule your campaign and so on okay
so
[Music]
we've displayed previously the always
the user keys so app script generates a
specific user key for each user and send
it to to tag River logging but in fact
if you if user send you a support
request you have to match this user and
his email address with a specific user
key and so in yet rules of mail merge
we are using firebase as our database
where we are storing user profiles and
so in each user profile we are stirring
the user key so that when someone ask
for help we were able to open his user
profile I get the user key and use that
to find the all logs related to the
specific user so to do that there's a
simply in app script you can call
session that get temporary active user
key and send that information to your
own database or so in our case we are
saying that to firebase and so that's
especially useful to investigate when
people are asking for help
also as it's yet another tool added to
add metrics and do some analytics on
usage of the add-on you might want to
aggregate everything in a single
dashboard and well the good news is that
data studio is here to help there have
been some other session about data
studio so I won't speak more about it
just that it is possible to build a
single
where you will aggregate information
from google analytics and information
from stackdriver
so you have everything in one single
place and it's not pretty but you can
actually do a very pretty dashboard with
at the studio okay so some resources so
if you want to have access to
stackdriver logging for now you have to
join the EAP year so you have the URL
for that there's also a documentation
explaining how to activate stackdriver
logging on your script and how to use it
especially the consulted log part and
everything outside of the basic error
logging there are documentation also on
how to export stackdriver logs to
bigquery so how to set the
synchronization up and also the query
reference to know better how to query
multiple table over a date range and all
the things like that I at the beginning
of the presentation I also spoke about
Google Analytics if you also want to
start using Google Analytics in your
add-ons know that there are some
specificities and so there's a blog post
available on the Google developer blog
about that about how to best use the
user IDs and a lot of other features in
Google Analytics for in the case of Apps
Script atoms and if you're interested in
using firebase as your database for your
add-on or any app script project there's
a core library and some examples that
are also available at this address
awesome thank you oh man that was that
was great thanks everybody for coming
Lee in the day it's great to see you
[Applause]
[Music]
you